humans have a poor track record with
understanding mental illness in ancient
times depression and anxiety were seen
as demonic possessions or supernatural
ailments people treated them with
religious rites and mystic rituals for
every civilization that rose and fell
there were just as many
misunderstandings and so-called cures
for people who experience the world
differently than their friends or peers
by the 18th century many had come to
vilify people with mental illnesses and
finding them to asylums deeming them a
menace to what we labeled normal society
fortunately in 2017 we have a more
compassionate albeit still developing
approach to mental illness we've
accepted that it's a pervasive obstacle
for people of all ages many of
experienced depression or anxiety
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder and
many have dedicated their careers to
studying understanding and treating
these problems but when it comes to art
and entertainment these problems are
still by and large taboo subjects
literature has tackled them sometimes
portraying stories from the perspective
of people suffering from depression or
post-traumatic stress disorder
mainstream movies have used mental
illness to provide shock value grotesque
villains or even comic relief the ones
we remember for their empathy and
authenticity are few and far between
so it caught me off guard to find such
empathy for mental illness in a
videogame of all places as someone who
has seen depression anxiety PTSD and
bipolar disorder up close it came as a
shock to find such an authentic take on
psychosis it's such a young medium one
originally built on fun competition and
escapism no less
not only is hell-blade Sen who has
sacrificed a great game in its own right
but one of the most honest and
empathetic portrayals of a mentally ill
character I've seen in entertainment
period
[Music]
hell-blade opens on senua a Celtic
Warrior on something like a Vision Quest
there are voices all around her it's not
too late to get into the boat at several
points she addresses the camera without
saying much at all hell-blade makes it
clear Senna is suffering this becomes
all the more apparent when we realize
that our surroundings aren't necessarily
real or at least not to anyone but senua
that is much of what we're seeing is
playing out in her mind she has
psychosis a symptom of mental illness
that can manifest in several different
ways but mainly hallucinations delusions
and a general detachment from the
objective world developer Ninja Theory
takes the traditional hero's journey
story structure and places it in a
mental health CAPTCHA paisa Noah's
psychosis it echos her chaotic tormented
mind she calls her symptoms of the
darkness and it permeates every aspect
of her environment if you suffer from
depression or anxiety then you know how
difficult they are to grasp their
impetuous there are elusive things
hell-blade illustrates Senna was coping
methods in the way she gives form to her
psychosis she creates physical
manifestations that are easier to fight
than the insidious emotions that mental
illnesses breathe we can't always battle
what we can't see
[Music]
seonhwa's personal struggles also
parallel those of North's mythology as
an off-screen character relays the
legends of Odin's Thor Loki and frere
these tales foreshadow the coming of
Ragnarok essentially it's the Norse
apocalypse when gods battle hellish
monsters and natural disasters resulting
in the end of one world and the
beginning of the next and the farther
into hell sena descends the closer she
gets to Ragnarok and the further the
story progresses the more we come to
realize just how much sin OA psychosis
has shattered her life this was a time
long before any cursory understanding of
mental illness existed her fellow tribes
people thought she was cursed someone
close to her treated her with cruelty
isolating her and severing her
connections with the outside world
what's more hell-blade explores the
pressure mental illness can put on a
relationship how it can cause rifts
between two people who care about each
other very much how it can give rise to
guilt when there's nothing they can do
to fight through one person's mental
anguish in one of the more clever moves
in recent game design memory ninja
theory tells you upfront that if you die
enough times
seonhwa will succumb to a disease that
sets her back to the beginning of her
journey as players this means we lose
our save file now at the publishing of
this video it's actually unclear how
this permadeath works or if it actually
works at all
some claim it's intentionally foggy on
ninja theories part while others say
it's an outright lie I can't tell you
one thing for certain though each time I
came close to death I began to sweat
each time I died I grew even more
anxious whether a permadeath system is
actually in place is beside the point
Ninja Theory effectively placed me in
the shoes of someone with irrational
dread and an omnipresent fear psychosis
can bring about both of these hell-blade
found a way to put me in some semblance
of that position but for all of the
oppressive aspects of Hell blaze world
and for all of the trials Santa WA
undergoes on her journey what's most
remarkable is how Ninja Theory handled
these heavy subjects throughout a seven
hour playthrough the studio never once
exploits cinema for shock value or
spectacle it uses her mental illness to
influence the gameplay in ways that make
sense for her character and also help us
under
and her emotions seonhwa's delusions
leader to see connections and signs in
the worlds that others might not she
creates connections in her surroundings
embracing her heightened imagination in
a way that aids her navigation through
her demonic hero's journey furthermore
although the voices in Santa's head are
often negative and sadistic they also
alert her to flanking enemies and help
her navigate the darkness depression
anxiety and bipolar disorder can often
warp your perception of time and here
too he'll bleed connects enemas
perspective with the way she navigates
her world
seonhwa may see her hallucinations and
capricious outlook as curses but they
can also help her sort through her grief
and loss they can help her cope with
trauma when no one else can understand
what she's feeling now we can't define
people by their mental illness they
contain multitudes after all and Ninja
Theory knows this Senna is a warrior a
lover and an ambitious person she is a
human being who happens to be battling a
painful combination of guilt confusion
and despair and it's all weakening her
mind this is her personal journey to not
only confront but also to conquer her
illness to use her humanity and
imagination to stare her grief in the
face and to hopefully drive a sword
through its heart
but there's nothing to go back to
naturalistic hell-blade is a remarkable
depiction of mental health problems not
just for how it conveys the symptoms and
emotions of people who suffer from them
but for how it empathizes with them as
well make a mistake this took guts on
the part of ninja theory it took courage
to play psychosis at hell-blade center
and even more to do so with authenticity
mental illness may be the center of this
game but empathy is its fuel this is the
story of Ragnarok but it's not one of
mythical proportions and godly battles
this is cinemas personal Ragnarok one
that signifies the end of one world and
the birth of another it's a game set in
a time with no understanding of mental
illness yet as a modern story it blazes
a trail
[Music]
[Music]